RONY ROZEN: As you
probably know by now
because you watched our
previous episode, adding support
for localization to your
app right from the start
is important.
Not sure why?
Need a refresher on the basic
use of NSLocalizedString?
Check out the previous episode.
I'll wait.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So at this point,
your app supports
one or more localizations.
As you're testing your app
in one of the new languages
it now supports,
you see that a word
you used in several
different places
in the English
version of your app
needs to be translated
in different ways
in Portuguese, for example.
Maybe your combination
poker telephone
app uses the word "call"
in two different ways--
placing a telephone
call and matching a bet.
This is how it's going to look
like in the localization file.
One translation, since these
are two uses of the same key,
with both comments so
that the translator will
know where and when it's used.
If you want to
separate this into two
different translations, this is
what it's going to look like.
But wait-- we now have two
translations for the same key.
That's obviously problematic.
How will the app know
which key to use when?
Well one way to resolve this
is to create two different keys
with the same translation
in the English version.
This of course means
that we'll also
need to change the code
accordingly and use
"CallPhone" and "CallBet"
instead of just "Call."
It also means that unless we
provide the translation files
for the English version
of the app where
the vast majority of
translations are simply
wrote with identical
texts on both
the left and the right
side of the equation,
the user will actually see
"CallPhone" and "CallBet"
and not "Call," but
it will at least allow
us to provide each
language with the most
appropriate translation for it.
We won't usually need
to use this technique
but it's good to
know it's an option.
And it also helps demonstrate
how important the comment
parameter actually is.
There are several other
elements of your app
that you should localize when
launching to new locales--
images, for example.
Let's say you're working
on a stock market app
and want to use an image
symbolizing a successful market
so that your users will be
happy, optimistic, and eager
to continue using your app.
You'll probably
choose an image that
looks roughly like this, right?
The problem is that
if you show this image
to a person in
China, for example,
they are likely to look at
your app in a negative way.
There, they have
reverse connotations
for the red and green colors,
so your image should actually
look like this instead.
The way you do this
is quite simple
and requires no
core-level changes.
Similar to what we did before
with the localization files,
all you need to do is
use two different images
with the same name--
one in the en.lproj folder,
the other in the zh folder.
This way, the English
version of your app
will use the green image, the
Chinese version of your app
will use the red image, and all
of your users will be happy,
which is all we
really want, right?
We used images for
this example, but you
can do the same thing
with audio files
and pretty much any file
type you can think of.
Xcode also supports the standard
XML Localization Interchange
File Format, or XLIFF.
This is especially
useful when you
have texts that are set
via Interface Builder--
whether zip files
or storyboards.
Instead of using the script we
used in the previous episode,
you can select a
project or a target
in the Xcode project
editor, and then
choose Editor, Export
For Localization.
This will generate
an en.xliff file,
assuming you're using English
as your base language.
This file will
include the strings
from all [INAUDIBLE]
Storyboard files
in addition to ones we
specified with NSLocalizeString.
You can send this XLIFF
file to the translator
and get a translated version.
For Spanish, for example,
it will be es.xliff.
You'll import the translated
files back into Xcode
by selecting the project or
target in the Xcode project
editor and choosing Editor,
Import Localizations.
The nice thing about
using this method,
in addition to it
being a format that
is well-known by
translation companies,
is that it allows you to only
worry about new translations
because each time you
import localization,
the string files are merged with
your existing project files.
And if you have strings that
are set in Interface Builder
and not via code, you only need
to worry about one localization
file per language instead
of having one .strings file
for each [INAUDIBLE] Storyboard
file and an additional
localizable .strings file
for the strings set via code.
The last point I want to
make about localization
is that it's
important to remember
that words in
different languages
have different length,
so it's important to test
your UI in all supported locales
and see that none of the words
get truncated, drops
a line, et cetera.
English tends to be
a compact language,
so words may end
up being translated
to something with twice
as many letters or words.
If you want to display
the number of views
in a post on your new social
media app, for example,
you'll need 15 characters
in Italian instead
of just five in English.
And don't forget to
consider the opposite case.
Shorter words can be just as
problematic as longer ones
if your UI was designed
for a specific word length.
My main point is basically
be aware of the changing word
sizes in different
translations and account for it
right from the start,
already at the design stage.
I want to leave you
with the concept
of internationalization.
In addition to having
users who speak and read
different languages,
being a word-friendly app
also means that you need to
internationalize your app.
What does that mean?
Well, it may mean supporting
right-to-left displays
for RTL languages such
as Hebrew and Arabic.
It may mean supporting
reverse uses of decimal points
and commas, as is customary
in many European countries.
It basically means knowing
your target audience
and what they care about so
that you can design the best
app for their needs, and happy
users lead to happy developers.
I hope you find this
helpful and will
use this new knowledge to build
more global-friendly apps.
I encourage you to look into
additional IOS localization
topics we didn't get to
discuss, such as locking
your views while waiting
for translations,
testing the translations
directly in Xcode,
or handling different
units of measurement.
Until next time, I'm
Rony Rozen for Route 85.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]